c'est une victoire pour la présidente
sortante de la région ile-de-france
valérie pécresse arrive largement en
tête au premier tour de ces régionales
en atteignant 35 96 % des voix dans les
yvelines et dépasse même les 40 % des
suffrages
la tête de liste de l'union de la droite
creuse l'écart dès le premier tour avec
le rassemblement national
nous avons fait prendre à la région le
cap de la sécurité et les valeurs de la
république
le cap de l'écologie des résultats le
cap de la relance et de l'emploi le cap
de la justice et nous la réduction des
fractures territoriales il sociale c'est
comme cela que j'ai fait reculer
l'extrême droite par la fermeté des
valeurs et mon engagement en faveur des
territoires ruraux jusque-là amende
année seul point noir au tableau la
forte abstention de près de 70% des
inscrits une source d'inquiétude pour le
président du sénat gérard larcher qui
salue la victoire des listes de la
droite et du centre
si ce soir la démocratie a repris ses
droits l'abstention très élevé des
mondes que notre pays est encore en
souffrance mais le scrutin est clair une
confiance largement renouvelée au
président de la droite et du centre avec
des scores plus élevés qu'en 2000 cache
la crise sanitaire a montré au fond la
capacité de ses présidents de région de
ses présidents de département à être
présents
si jordan bardella est distancé tout
comme la liste de la république en
marche l'attention de valérie pécresse
se porte sur les listes de gauche pour
le second tour l'écologiste julien bayou
devrait porter une liste d'union avec
audrey pulvar et clémentine autain
maintenant il faut confirmer le score
attention rien n'est gagné
on a une gauche qui va s'allier avec une
extrême gauche qui s'oppose à la laïcité
qui prône le port du burkini à dans les
bases de loisirs pour ne citer que ces
exemples
si tout reste à concrétiser au second
tour ce score est une confirmation de l'
influence de valérie pécresse dans la
sphère politique française
elle qui a quitté les républicains pour
fonder son mouvement libre pense
peut-être aux présidentielles de 2022
ce qu'on vend en ile de france et que la
méthode pécresse marche
ce café valérie pécresse fonctionne donc
ce duel qu'on a voulu nous imposer entre
le rassemblement national et la
république en marche on voit quand tout
cas en ile de france il n'existe pas le
rempart aujourd'hui est la meilleure
garantie de protéger la république c'est
valérie pécresse et il faut que c'était
lent perdure d'abord pour le second tour
des élections régionales
il faut face à valérie pécresse trois
listes seront en lice julien bayou
autour d'une union de la gauche jordan
bardella pour le rassemblement national
et laurent saint martin pour la
république en marche
les franciliens sont appelés aux urnes
le dimanche 27 juin